there's a new 50 55 plus community
coming to town that is convenient
luxurious fun and secure we got a sneak
peek of the property before the grand
opening this summer
we're excited to be here at trilogy
sunstone here in the northwest part of
las vegas trilogy sunstone
will be a large master planned community
we're part of a larger master plan
community called sunstone
and so here at trillage is really the
active lifestyle of the 55 plus
community
part of the sunstone master plan
[Music]
our community will consist of about 930
homes we'll have
13 floor plans across four different
product lines
we have some single-family detachable
range anywhere from 1 300 square feet to
2 600 square feet
really the plans live open they're large
large plants that live open really
designed for entertainment indoor
outdoor living we're really excited to
bring this product to market
[Music]
so trilogy is all about the lifestyles
we have trilogies across the country and
trilogy is known for creating a
a community where you feel like you're
at a resort all the time so we have a a
wonderful clubhouse club cabochon will
be the center the kind of the heartbeat
of the community and that will be
consist about 15 000 square feet
resort swimming pool about pickleball
bocce ball
along with a great fitness center and in
a restaurant as well so really something
for everybody
you wake up in the morning you'll be
able to go down and work out at the club
and then be able to hang out and you
know
have a martini at the pool in the
afternoon trilogy will consist of
um trails throughout the community
they'll also interconnect with the
master plant community of
sunstone so this avid trail system will
connect and have
a great opportunity for walking and
running trails throughout the entire
community
the entire community of trilogy is a
guard gated community will be
completely gated around with access
control at the front gate trilogy
sunstone is expecting the grand opening
in the summer of 2021 as we finish the
model right behind us
so here at trilogy we've actually
released i've had two releases and doing
our third one here soon
all of them been fully reserved so we're
excited that the
feedback and the people that are you
know that are coming in they're really
excited to be a part of trilogy
we invite everybody that's interested to
contact us you can look us up on our
on our website give us a call and sign
up to be on our priority list or vip
priority link
for more information on this new 55 plus
community
call 800 685 64
or visit sheahomes.com sunstone
jc overdue